okay i showed you how to do the flat the  fitted sheet now we're going to do the  flat sheet so you take the top of the  sheet  with the bottom corner and we're going  to put these together so you're going to  fold the long way first then you're  going to take the top  and bring it  and we're gonna  we're gonna  overlay  the top part of the sheet with the  bottom but the seam has to be inside and  then what we're gonna do is take this  sheet the fitted one put it inside oh  man and then  just like that  it's like a nice little sausage  and  beautiful and it'll sit in your closet  and then what you can do is you can put  a little pin on it and tell you what  size when sheets are in the closet it's  always difficult to know what size they  are so i wrote on here it's a queen  sheet i use a safety pin and i put it  right on there then you know what it is